let me rewind man wants success and the
grand prize is a hot woman
women want success what is the prize
for that success we're talking success
like
career-wise yeah um a lot of money and
lonely usually
usually an empty apartment but a lot of
money to spend
and that's not doesn't sit well with you
i mean i think people are free to choose
what they want to choose if that's what
you want to do go do it like but i i
think a lot of women do that and they
chase the bag and they chase the career
and then they find themselves alone at
50 60
and it that's not fun and i think and i
think a lot of older women lie to
younger women about this and that's what
rubs me the wrong way that's why i do
what i do because i just don't believe
in lying to women how do women older
women lie to younger women because
they'll say things like like the
happiest sector of women
is like 45 and childless but you could
find 10 studies that disprove that for
the one that they have that didn't have
a proper sample size so you're pushing
this narrative because you don't want to
be alone in your poor choices
and i just that doesn't sit well with me
at all so they're almost like validating
their poor decisions is what you're
saying yeah and you can see it in the
media all the time like every poor
decision a woman makes like you see it
in the media like for example like women
gain weight right what body positivity
that's the next thing that comes out we
just talked about yeah jordan peterson
rollo yeah yeah the one big girl was on
the cover of s.i yeah and and i've been
overweight and that you can lose it so
why are we tripping
like why are we tripping and they do the
same thing with age now too you see them
pushing
like what is it ageism that's the new
word oh yes because the older women are
upset that they're lonely yeah yeah
they're mad that they're not getting the
same sexual offers that they were
getting in their youth shocking yeah
coco your found success in what you're
doing
same question to you men find success
and the grand prize is women what is the
grand prize for being a successful woman
freedom and money
because when you have your own career
you obviously make money if you're
successful
money equals freedom so you can do
whatever you want
but
to pearl's point let's say you're that
45 year old woman successful millionaire
amazing house you know couple cats
running around shout out to the cat
owners out there but would that be
fulfilling if you never got married and
had dinner
i don't think that you can't be
successful
and have a husband or a boyfriend or
whatever i don't think it's either or
you can do both is what you're saying
yeah because i see it right now like me
and my boyfriend we both work literally
24 7. like we work weekends we like we
work all the time but we both work from
home
okay we both go on meetings go to shoots
and whatever whatever he goes do for his
work but we're still there and we're
still enjoying each other and i what i
love that's why i said that what we
appreciate with each other we're both
very ambitious and we talk about work a
lot and we work on projects together so
it's not that he is doing his own thing
and i'm doing my own thing and we don't
even know what's going on in our
work life do you think do you think he
respects you more because you've got a
lot going on yes he said that he he
would never be with a girl who doesn't
who's not driven got it so respect to
him and and have you ever been with a
guy who found you a little much like too
work oriented like you're a little
intimidating have you been with a guy
like that ever i wouldn't say that i was
ever like intimidating
at least nobody told me that
but i know that a lot of guys don't like
when a girl is very vocal about her
opinion and i'm very vocal about my
opinion so when it comes to being
submissive
i couldn't do that because that's just
not my personality but that's not my
personality and that's why i left the
comfort of my own home that's why i'm
trying to do my own thing
[Music]